Hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week on
Teen Wolf they paid off the young Derek plot
and teased the Benefactor, the main villain
of season 4.
There were a few funny moments, but the Kate
Were-Jaguar story turned out to be something
way sneakier.
Before we get started Hello to any new people
who are just finding me, I'm doing weekly
Teen Wolf videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'm also going to try and do bonus videos
too.
I was really glad they resolved the big mystery
of young derek in episode 1, but because the
real story was something totally different
we need to spend most of our time talking
about that.
So what I'm going to do is Top 5 Moments,
then a quick breakdown of the new character
they introduced and what he's going to be
doing this season and then an overall review
of the episode.
Careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet, but here we go.
Number 5 - Malia Meets Peter
So in case you missed it last season, Malia
is Peter's biological daughter, her mother
was Mrs Tate, married to Mr Tate.
Her mother had an affair with Peter, but she
was raised as Mr Tate's daughter.
Everyone thought she died, but then during
season 3 she appeared after living as a coyote
for years.
Cut to now where she's completely failing
at history class in the most adorable way
possible.
Her meeting Peter was huge, Peter knew exactly
who she was but she doesn't know he's her
father.
Remember earlier in the episode Scott told
Stiles that telling the truth was always the
best way to go.
Them not telling Malia about Peter will probably
bite them in the ass later this season, literally.
Malia would totally bite someone.
I also caught some Peter vibes coming off
Malia, she's got a lot of his rage and impulsiveness.
Peter is a little more subtle just having
the benefit of years of experience but I can
totally see his subconscious presence in her.
Not like when he was controlling Lydia, but
shades of him behind her eyes.
I wonder if that means there's a high likelihood
she'll betray the pack for Peter when she
learns the truth.
I think Stiles is her anchor, so if she were
ever forced to choose I think the outcome
would depend on where their relationship is
and what he does to win her back.
Doesn't it kind of seem like anyone associated
with the Hale family gets tied up in a betrayal
plot sooner or later.
Even Derek who was BFFs with Scott during
season 3 had been an antagonist before that.
Definitely a high probability of Malia flip
flopping sides back and forth this year.
Number 4 - Kate Wants To Control Her Shifting
It was a little confusing, Kate was being
manipulated just like she was manipulating
Young Derek.
She really did want the Triskelion so she
could control her shifting.
And Yes, I do think she'll listen to Peter's
advice and figure it out on her own eventually.
It's been a while since I've seen the triskelion
symbol too so whenever Peter called it out
I actually thought of the Triskelion on Marvel's
Agents of SHIELD.
It's a giant base that doubles as prison for
supervillains in the Marvel Universe.
The Hale Family's Triskelion means a bunch
of different things, usually each time it
shows up like in season 1, season 2 and season
3.
It's a metaphor for something different.
In greek and celtic mythology it represents
the stages of life, like birth, life, death
and the stages of the moon.
New, half and Full.
In this episode I think for Derek and Kate
it represents Past, Present and Future because
of their previous relationship and Derek's
physical transformation.
But for Peter and Malia I think it represented
Mother, Father, Daughter.
It's all about progression, family and relationships.
Which is what a lot of this episode teased.
Number 3 - Lydia's Powers Start To Manifest
More
So Lydia spacing out into Banshee mode and
finding the murder scene is going to keep
happening until she learns to control her
powers.
Just like Kate is trying to learn to control
her shifts.
I like to think they're on the same path,
learning to control their demon powers, even
though Kate is a were jaguar I'm just going
to think of her as a demon.
A really nasty one.
I like that they used the cell phone pictures
for comedy.
It wouldn't be Lydia if they didn't try to
make if funny.
I feel like her comedic powers exist in a
direct relationship with her proximity to
Stiles.
The closer they drift together, the funnier
she gets.
I can't imagine how sticky that bathroom was
after they filmed that scene.
In some of the trailers we saw scenes of Lydia
investigating murders, this goes into the
idea of the Benefactor and the Deadpool List
which I'll explain in a second.
But there's going to be a lot of serial killings
going on.
For Lydia it will be like moth to flame.
So until she learns to control her power,
in each new episode she's going to space out
and just show up at random dead bodies.
I like that they used a bathroom for this
first big kill.
I kind of thought it was a callback to the
bathroom in episode 1, the one Kate refused
to kill
Number 2 - Young Derek Transformers Back to
Regular Derek
This was another logic jump the show was asking
you to make, but remember he was transforming
back while he was going apeshit on the berserkers.
Who knew young derek was so good at krav maga
and parkour?
This was all happening while Peter was explaining
how to use anger to control the shift.
It made me think that young Derek just tapped
into his primal rage and that's what caused
him to revert back to normal.
The only issue I had with this was they didn't
do a great job of explaining the mechanics
of young Derek.
Like what kind of a spell did Kate use to
make his body and mind revert to a younger
state and if a young Derek could transform
into old Derek using raw emotion, how come
Old Derek can't do the same thing in reverse.
Feel free to write your theory about the time
travel magic in the comments.
But I think Stiles dad making the silly timey
wimey explanation was a note to us the viewers
from the writers saying, don't poke too many
holes in this.
And my Number 1 Moment - The Benefactor Appears
and Reveals The True Plan
It's a bit of a deus ex machina, but that
person at the end is The Benefactor.
He's the main villain this season and the
one who used Kate to get to the Bearer Bonds.
All kinds of questions here but I have a few
theories about why he took the money.
Creator Jeff Davis was talking about the idea
of the Deadpool list in season 4.
A kill list of all the supernatural creatures
living in Beacon Hills.
The Benefactor is behind it or will be behind
it and I think he's going to use those Bearer
Bonds to finance the kills.
He has to pay out when someone kills a name
on the list.
So presumably, a hunter could make a shit
load of money by killing a bunch of werewolves,
kanima or anything else living in the area.
Joseph Gatt is the actor listed as playing
the Benefactor.
In case you didn't see it, he played a warg
on Game of Thrones Season 4.
You can't tell from this picture, but he's
super huge.
Like as big as one of the berserkers.
It's unclear why the Benefactor character
wants all the supernatural creatures dead,
but we can eliminate some familiar faces from
being responsible, like Peter.
It's seemed like he genuinely flipped out
when his money was stolen.
But wouldn't it be crazy if this was like
Usual Suspects and he was the Verbal Kint,
the Kevin Spacey character that secretly turns
out to be Kaiser Sose.
I don't think that's what's going on, but
I like the idea that Peter is the Loki of
the series, always the trickster.
You can never trust your eyes or ears when
he's around.
He's always working some long con to regain
his alpha status.
Remember, his eyes still glow blue, not Alpha
Red.
So let me know what your favorite moment was
and why do you think the Benefactor wants
to kill all supernatural creatures in Beacon
Hills.
And will it cause a mega alliance to form.
There's a lot more than just werewolves living
there.
Here's a couple important things that didn't
make it into my top 5, but that are important.
The pairings.
I liked the way they mixed and matched characters
from last episode.
Last week it was Kira and Malia, this week
we saw Kira go off with Lydia.
I really like the way pairing people brings
unexpected energy.
Like when Malia went off with Scott and Peter
had what was probably the funniest line in
the episode "We're not exactly a brain trust
of geniuses here".
You wouldn't get that if they always paired
Scott with Stiles because Stiles is the genius.
I'm really looking forward to more Malia Peter
scenes, we still need to see Stiles and Kira
get some moments and Malia and Lydia, actually
I take it all back, Malia and Lydia is who
I want to see together next.
They can go all Scooby Doo on one of Lydia's
murder scenes.
The Kira Scott relationship is probably going
to take the longest to get anywhere but I
think it will.
Malia and Stiles are definitely a thing and
Stiles and Lydia are like the sexless old
couple that just crack jokes.
Or like buddy cops that have an unconsummated
relationship.
Stiles and Lydia would make for a great True
Detective Season 2
And Malia is now my new favorite character.
She's got all of the right qualities to kick
butt while getting herself into hilarious
situations and stay adorable while she's making
a mess of things.
Like history class.
She's like a puppy.
You can't get mad at a puppy.
Scott is still on the path to becoming a leader
even though he's a true alpha.
That whole history speech about great leaders
failing greatly was foreshadowing for him.
It's not a spoiler since Jeff Davis explained
the new character Liam.
But he's going to be Scott's beta.
I don't know how or why Scott will turn him,
but remember what the Calvares said.
If he ever turned a person they'd come for
him too.
So eventually they'll show up, for better
or worse.
Hopefully they'll help with Kate while they're
around.
Overall I thought the episode was a solid
B plus, it did an okay job of resolving the
Derek plot even if the explanation defied
logic.
And it did a good job of setting up the interpack
dynamics and plots going forward.
Detective Banshee, Failed Leader made stronger
by the experience and the romantic 'ships.
We still need to meet the new freshman lacrosse
players which I think is in episode 3.
But in the meantime, I'll try to get a bonus
video out next Monday, be sure to subscribe
to get it.
I think I'll either make it about the lore
of the Triskelion or feel free to suggest
some other aspect of Teen Wolf lore.
Right now click here for my episode 1 review
and click here for my personal Q&A I did during
VidCon.
I answer all kinds of weird questions about
myself you guys asked me.
It was fun.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!